good afternoon I'm Patty Brennan the
director of the National Library of
Medicine and today I'm excited to have
you join me in a conversation with one
of our most distinguished investigators
Dr Eugene coonan today our conversation
is going to travel through a wide range
of ideas from the communication of cells
across time to the comparison of viruses
and other cellular life
Dr coonan's thinking about how various
life forms evolve over time has been
instrumental in driving many discoveries
in contemporary biology
did you start out experimentally or
computationally to study viruses or did
they become a serviceable good model for
you to study Evolution uh I started my
career as an experimental virologist of
trying to study RNA viruses Maybe
without outstanding success but soon
after oh
these RNA viruses have indeed become
an excellent probably best at the time
playground or for the emerging
discipline of comparative genomics
because for the simple reasons that at
the time these were the complete genomes
that could could be sequenced what got
you into the computational tools for
understanding viruses
the first complete genomes of any
biological entities have started to
accumulate and these biological entities
at the time were exclusively small
viruses
and these represented both an
opportunity and a challenge
or an opportunity because these were
complete genomes to compare and try to
understand a challenge or because
without special effort without
developing dedicated computational
approaches very little could be
understand from those sequences in a
sense or they were a disappointment
because they call the technological
achievement but at the same time these
were just long strings of four letters
or from which no one could really
understand much that required special
efforts I don't think that the community
at the time was entirely prepared for
that situation but it was rectified
fairly through and
I
I'm very pleased to have played some
role in that
well we've talked before about your
interest in genomic Evolution and that
the the manner in which organisms change
over time and I'd like you to talk a
little bit about that now and if you
could specifically talk a little about
the challenge of understanding
conservation versus mutation
oh
genomes that exists exist on our planet
or result from billions and millions of
years of evolution
to put it very simply
um when we compare genomes of
either closely related or distantly
related organisms
we delineate conserved and less concert
variable parts and what we can see is
that the highly concerned part are
involved in functions that are essential
for the organisms or organism survival
conversely
the parts that are variable
contain genes
or that are involved in
interactions between organisms and in
interactions between organisms and the
environment so when you speak about
conserve this is not only sections of
the gene that appear over generations of
the organism but also that appear
commonly across groups of organisms it's
useful to note that by now it's a firmly
established plain fact that all cellular
organisms I'm not talking about viruses
organisms that exist on this planet
originate from a single common ancestor
so-called Luca lost Universal cellular
ancestor that
existed about 4 billion years ago just a
little bit less maybe well this was a
probably the most brilliant hypothesis
in the history of science proposed by
none other than Charles Darwin the
entire history of Life the unimaginably
wrong
history of Life on our planet spanning
about 4 billion years
um
is permeated by persisting evolutionary
relationships or there is to be even a
little more specific there is about a
hundred of genes that are shared by all
cellular organisms from mammals to
plants to Amoeba two bacteria
I'm going to turn your our attention to
your experiences here at the National
Library of Medicine you've been here 30
years
and actually even a little longer a
little longer yeah exactly exactly 31.
no 31 years
um and you're you have had an
illustrious career many trainees and
many many papers I wonder if you can
talk a little bit about how the National
Library of medicine's resources have
shaped your work and how you have helped
shape our resources
it has been an incredibly welcoming and
fertile environment for the
evolution of my own scientific career my
my research group and combined the very
good resources we don't need that much
but but what we do need the
computational resources were funds to to
to publish combining that with
[Music]
um
pretty much unlimited academic freedom
which
sounds almost too good to be true but
nevertheless it's true you spoke at one
time of the importance of the blast
algorithm for your work and then further
modifications of that could you speak a
little bit about the analytical tools
that you use and what we provide for
that is a
centerpiece of
um
computational biology and genomics that
completely
indispensable
tool which
quickly Compares
sequences of nucleic acids and or
proteins and there are
um at the time of its development which
incidentally coincided with my arrival
here
um
uh this was by far superior by any other
available method it was actually
the only real game in town
the only way to
efficiently compare
um Gene and genomic sequences very
timely uh development I don't think that
any other
um to a method developed here really
compared to the breath in importance
it should be noted however that there is
substantial competition in the road now
but hopefully
advances the field as a whole I'd like
you to reflect for a moment on the
contribution that you Delight in the
most in your scientific career
perhaps I should mention the crispr
system
what crispr is is widely known because
this is
known as the new methodology
um
[Music]
for genome engineering and editing Which
is far more efficient and fast and
previously available once but
um in in biology itself this this is
something also of great interest or
because crispr is a adoptive immunity
system
in in microbes in in bacteria
um
and uh before this was discovered it was
not even no one even suspected that
adoptive immunity
fundamentally similar to ro
existed in a bacteria and with my
colleagues
through
or comparative genomics approaches as
usual
We Have Been instrumental into the
discovery and fairer characterization of
this system
many Labs contributed but I think
I think our contribution is noticeable I
guess if I need to mention one
achievement that would be that
I want to close by congratulating you on
your election to the National Academy of
Medicine this year I was quite proud to
have another member of our nlm staff
become recognized so widely for critical
contributions and I congratulate you
personally thank you so much it's some
certainly certainly uh